la crisis sanitaria desatada por la
pandemia de kobe 19 avanza en haití el
país más pobre de américa donde la
convulsa situación política agravada por
el magnicidio del presidente moix
dificulta el funcionamiento de la
administración y el acceso a los
recursos sanitarios a las afueras de la
capital puerto príncipe el personal del
hospital sanlúcar lamenta además que la
población sólo acuda al médico cuando su
situación es extremadamente grave lo que
colapsa los escasos medios disponibles a
veces tenemos 60 pacientes en el
hospital que necesitan oxígeno y sólo
tenemos ies tanques de oxígeno
disponibles en las áreas donde podríamos
conseguir oxígeno son inaccesibles es
una situación muy estresante para
nosotros en el hospital
los datos oficiales revelan 20.000
contagios y 537 muertes desde el inicio
de la pandemia en un país de casi 12
millones de habitantes
el personal sanitario considera que las
cifras no representan la realidad debido
a la falta de tests
sin embargo constatan la baja mortalidad
causada por el virus
debemos tener de las tasas de contagios
más altas del mundo seguro
pero los haitianos son fuertes por sus
condiciones de vida resisten mejor a las
infecciones que otras personas
el hospital sanlúcar empezará a inocular
en los próximos días las 500.000 dosis
donadas por estados unidos a través del
mecanismo kóvacs según las últimas
cifras del 27 de julio ni un 1% de la
población ha recibido la pauta completa
de vacunación